hot cider oh yes thank you barb thank
you so much really hmm
wow that's got to kick i'll be the wrong
ah i can feel it warming up your belly
still in my mouth and throat well leslie
it's starting to get nippy huh you guys
want to walk down to the duck pond that
sounds lovely i'll get the gun are you
all coming y'all
we don't say y'all yeah we do no well
yeah we say it
here but not normally well did you ever
think this is how i really talk and that
i talk differently when i'm not here
y'all fighting no no sweetie we're just
having a conversation about how your
daddy can be so stuck up cam that's
really mature use our daughter to get
your little digs in i would never do
that sweetie you don't think i notice
how condescending you are when we come
here you just sit on the porch you roll
your eyes you don't participate in
anything and yeah i said set but that's
how we talk here i'm from this place i'm
proud of this place and it hurts me that
the man i love just thinks it's some big
joke come on sweetie
lord of
mercy hey was that aunt marge just
tearing down the driveway yes and she
dropped off a little present is that my
cam chair graham graham oh yeah there's
been some storm warning so marge thought
she'd be safer over here when she
dropped her off so fast that we didn't
even have a chance to straighten up oh
we never told graeme about the gay you
know after they reach a certain age you
worry that it could be the thing that
sends them over the edge and she's been
on the edge for a long time we're
actually on deathbed number two
mitchell mitchell okay what what's this
this is me ready to slop bail or milk
something you don't need to do that no i
did cam i i know i know i gave you hell
for for being who you really are and i
want to make that up to you yeah but you
know what putting on my sister's sunday
overalls is gesture enough what's this
oh it's my chewing straw it's not strong
oh it's just show okay for sure come on
you know you love the man you love the
world he comes from yeah i don't know if
it's these farming clothes or what i am
feeling so
close to you right now that's so sweet
give me a kiss not right now well don't
make me wrastle you down
who's this oh dear uh well grams this is
bud our new farm hand
bud yeah bud's a little simple-minded on
account of getting mule kicked idney and
you know the rules on being in the house
but now go on outside we're gonna milk
the cows in a few minutes
get on out there have a treat afterwards
i'm done i'm done come on please just be
bud for a couple days you can do some
chores maybe i can berate you a little
bit to really sell it do you hear how
insane you sound
chores
all right you know what you do with your
grandmother however you want lily and i
will just go get a hotel room no you
can't find motel silo whatever you got
around here no that alarm means there's
a tornado coming right now god well
where's lily i hope she's not still on
the field
you can't just call her like a pig
this is just a farm thing not like a
mall thing what's that city voice
don't be nervous honey there's nothing
to be scared of take it easy mama don't
break your hip
i'm telling you right now i am not
pretending to be something i'm not
especially in front of our daughter oh
so i can't kiss you in front of your dad
for six years and you can't give me two
days we're saving an old lady some
unnecessary upset why don't you give her
a little credit she might be more
open-minded than you think well you're a
cute little chinese thing
actually graham she's uh from vietnam
and her name's lily
dad how long do you have to stay down
here
dad
okay well i guess there's no way around
this
act actually ma'am
she's my kin so you got a chinese wife
bud no i i went to vietnam and i did
myself some adopting
and now i'm raising her oh by my
lonesome
well i never thought i'd live long
enough to see that
none of us did
but i guess there's nothing more
important than family
no matter how they come well that is
mighty open-minded of you some folks
around these parts don't share that
progressive i say progressive
sensibility to each his own but i do
wish i had another little one like that
to spoil
what if i told you you did have a great
grandbaby
what
cam it's okay mama
what if i told you i was in love
and that i've never been happier in my
entire life
and that i'm about to get married i
can't think of anything better and what
if i told you the love of my life
is this man standing right here
then i'd know why god sent us this
tornado
after the initial shot gramps softened a
bit she even agreed to attend the
wedding standing outside with the sign
baby steps mitchell baby steps
[Music]
you